hello reject nation
I'm Greg elbow I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch an old-ass video from
Stephen Amell American Ninja Warrior see
Stephen Amell is quite an athlete he's
very athletic he's even in some
wrestling videos does a lot of his own
stunts in the show era and I love the
guy some people think he's a really
stoic performer I think he's incredibly
charming
I like his stoic Ness anywho I did see
this video when it first came out I
mentioned that to the guy who requested
this you see over gurkha patreon we do
TV show reaction watching logs that
includes attack on side of my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and also supernatural
Riverdale in Gotham job does music video
coverage and we do weekly Q days are one
of our top of war tiers whatever video
you requested us definitely do it put up
all the youtubes and today comes from
Michael B who has a YouTube channel
called Omni media it's a really good
channel what reactions reviews the guys
very talented very knowledgeable very
nice guy we have long messages back and
forth he knows that I've seen this
before John is not nope never never once
although I haven't seen Stephen Amell in
a wrestling ring and that was pretty
impressive so I'm excited as the first
wrestling match John attended yeah first
of many personally I'm a big wrestling
fan it helps to take my own you know
part in the sport gonna get a mask or
something jump in the ring is I'm gonna
do great well very buff let's put those
headphones objects all I remember is how
this ends I don't remember most of what
happens really I've never liked the last
thing he says or something like I
remember be like that's a fun
[Applause]
and this red time to do it he's got
millions of followers on social media
who encouraged him to trial
a lot of his own studies he's excited
about seeing the show you see them with
the [ __ ] of this dude is Jack while he's
6 1 and just solid muscle
watch up there's the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
i watch this before
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well this would be another $5,000 for
Red Nose Day and it's a big moment for
Stephen and his fans where it is the
brutal Salmon Ladder can he do it
no doesn't allow all right here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's a good frame boy I bet that woman
was trying to sleep with him and his
wife that is crazy that's impressive man
that was incredible
I'd like to see some Marvel hero try
that [ __ ] yeah Chris Evans were you
gonna do that I mean I wonder I don't
think Robert his character doesn't ride
on actually being buff yeah I mean
though he is buff he's not like oh it's
certainly better than I am but further
Darbar yeah I don't know I think you
could take Robert Danny yeah Chris Evans
god no Chris Hemsworth oh yeah you can
find the funny one to me this is
inspiring especially because he does
play a superhero
I mean it's not superhero it's pretty
ridiculous
arrows he just non-stop always wears a
fellow with heightened villages yes so
the fact that he does play a hero on a
very famous show and then you know you
see how much he can actually do in real
life it actually makes it that much more
believable I wish that he could get more
action hero Roy yeah yeah well it of
Casey and Ninja Turtles to like you know
is he got more Casey jumps Stacy
I feel he's worthy of being like a much
more famous action hero but yeah this
seems like a really down-to-earth family
guy I he's a family I do have an
Instagram account that I have logged
onto in a few weeks but I do follow
Stephen Amell and he loves to go live on
there he's a funny guy and he seems like
super family-oriented I think he's
Canadian estheban about Canadian of the
only thing I would explain why he's so
nice it's the only way this kind of
human being is positive is born in
Canada raised there foremost was Rob
Stephen Amell - Ron Johnson yeah this
has a Canadian personality doesn't he
yeah a little bit yet he's such a tough
guy on arrow well that's the the magic
about this video is watching him both
push himself but also just go the extra
mile for charity he seems like he's not
tired
the portrait he's like this is about the
end I was kind of surprised by that
because he doesn't look tired by the
time he got up to doing whatever the
Salmon Ladder things like all that like
that's uh I don't know it seems so hard
it seems terrifying to even approach the
practice proper yeah cuz you're gonna
you know that the first many times you
do it you're just gonna fall I think
it's like every muscle is required there
you got a little pull yourself up push
with your shoulders and chest land and
then pull again and you gotta like use
your core as well to lunge up please
pull the push the bar and you know and
then you know your your shoulder and
neck muscles not to pull your arms out
of there it's literally your entire
every upper body muscle is required to
do that yeah I don't know maybe Tyrone
magnets can do it I want to see Tyrone
on an American Ninja Warrior competition
get him aqus on you know you get all the
reactors and I was with Tyrone I would
just be the girl who's cheering on Steve
Tyrone yeah we have sex later you're hot
the people love you I love you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
man Stephen Amell I hope you're still
working out I'm not I don't like seeing
up to season I saw season 6 episode 2 of
arrow but then I kind of lost interest
after a committee I mean you don't want
to watch the same show indefinitely I'll
continue this later no I think he's a
very underrated talent feel like us
sometimes people criticize him for being
kind of a stoic performer but I'm like
that's the character and he manages to
exude charm through being a stoic
character if on that very hard to do I
love him as an actor and I think he's
got a great body
I do too all those promos I've seen for
arrow in the trailer I saw in the second
Ninja Turtles movie I mean he definitely
looks like a like something I would want
to see on a screen yeah so Hollywood I'm
not gonna start watching everybody's
dude gets Stephen Amell and some more
[ __ ] so I can see his charms let's go
with the wild wild west
Wow West's reboot Will Smith still and
Stephen Amell instead of Kevin yes or
Jaden Smith instead of Will Smith I
could work everybody wants that
subscribe for the reject nation click
that notification Bell check us out on
patreon and check down Michael beast
YouTube channel Baba